It's time for our next game,
Thugs Not Hugs.
Oh, boy.
This is one of my
favorite games.
This is a shiny new 2016 edition
of Thugs Not Hugs.
If you're not familiar
with the game,
please direct your attention
to the monitor.
WOMAN:
Say hello to the camera.
Hello, (bleep).
Starts off all cute and huggy
and reveals that he will not
take (bleep) from anybody.
So comedians,
we're gonna show you an image
of a cute child
and for 250 points
you're gonna tell us
if they're living a hug life
or a thug life.
First up, this
buckled little buddy.
-Koechner.
-Thug.
All right, let's find out.
-WOMAN: Oh, I love you.
-Catch it.
WOMAN:
Got it. Love you.
Oh, (bleep) in your mouth.
♪ (bleep) the police, comin'
straight from the underground ♪
He should know
that's a thing you can do
for at least another 13 years.
Next up, this child
let down by her best friend.
Thug life or hug life?
Hayes.
Hug, 'cause I have to believe
in the innocence of children.
All right, let's find out.
Let's find out.
(babbles)
VERMUELEN:
Aw.
-KOECHNER: Wait...
-And then the dog eats her face.
HARDWICK:
Then the dog eats her face.
Next up, this pint-sized driver.
This pint-sized driver.
Thug life or hug life?
Drée.
-Thug life.
-Yeah, let's find out.
Batman! Batman!
Oh!
Oh, no!
Oh.
He...
He ran over Batman.
I know, he was very happy.
Look at that sadistic,
deranged face.
Possibly the prequel
to Batman v Superman?
Could be, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's little Kal-El.
That's little Kal-El
right there,
running down little Batman.